peu
[Musique]
zéro de conduite c'est ce que vous
risquez automobilistes inexpérimentés
qui venait de passer votre permis à
l'instar de pierre dac à la veille des
vacances
apprenez d'abord à connaître votre
propre voiture et ne confondez pas le
démarreur avec n'importe quel autre
bouton ou le frein avec l'accélérateur
un démarrage plus rapide sans
signalisation zéro de conduite ou doublé
sur une route glissante zéro de conduite
et la page en chaîne
qui sent vivre où les consignes et on
n'existait pas zéro de conduite doublé
en haut d'une côte et marées en
s'imaginant qu'il n'ya au monde qu'une
seule voiture là contre zéro de conduite
oublier qu'il existe aussi des cyclistes
et des cyclistes imprudents ses héros de
conduite ne pas se mettre en mode
éblouir d'autres conducteurs stationnés
sur la route sans feux de position au
zéro de conduite
on est à fond comme on dit le pied au
plancher
ce héros de conduite méfiez vous de tous
c zéro de conduite la conducteurs
novices vaut ainsi conducteurs
expérimentés ils vous mènerez loin
beaucoup trop loin
[Musique]